[Music]
[Applause]
hey Luke here at the outdoor boys
YouTube channel and welcome to another
camp side cooking video now I'm going to
show you guys how to make the ultimate
campfire breakfast but don't worry you
can do this at home over a stove very
easily so I'm gonna walk you through it
I'm not gonna do a silent video this
time I'm gonna actually give you guys
instructions because I really think this
is something you guys are gonna want to
do at home well there's a lot of
different names for what we're gonna
make but I like to call it breakfast pie
it's a combination of all of my favorite
breakfast foods when I'm out camping now
to get started you're gonna need to chop
up some vegetables you're gonna be
chopping up whatever you think would
taste good in an omelet so I like sweet
bell peppers I like chives green onions
but you can add whatever you want yellow
onions mushrooms squash sprouts you name
it
[Music]
next we're gonna make the hash sprouts
and to do this I like russet potatoes
but you can also use red potatoes as
well
and you want big ones it'll just be a
lot less work peeling and shredding them
so take your rest potatoes skin them out
and then immediately submerge them in
cold water and you do this to keep them
from turning brown that nasty brown
color that potatoes turn when you leave
them exposed to air and once you've got
them all skinned then you're gonna shred
them with the face of cheese grater and
once again once you've got a pile of
shredded potato submerge it in cold
water once it's sat in the cold water
for a few minutes you want to agitate it
and stir it around a little bit in this
foam and the white stuff will come up to
the surface that's the starch you want
to get rid of the excess starch in the
potato otherwise you'll get kind of
these gluey gooey potato hash browns
next you're gonna strain it off take a
cheesecloth or a colander or something
and dump the potatoes into it get all
that starchy water out if you want to
save yourself some time you can buy pre
diced vegetables and you can use frozen
hash browns instead of making your own
from potatoes next fry up any meat you
want in the omelet portion of your
breakfast pie I lie
bacon and sausage now we're gonna take
about two pounds of bacon we're gonna
chop it up really fine we're gonna fry
those up till they're crispy and we're
gonna set those aside if you have bacon
lardons you can also use those instead
once you have fired up all that bacon
and sausage you're gonna have a nice bit
of grease in the bottom of your pan save
that grease you're gonna use that to
cook your hashbrowns nothing better than
cooking hash browns and bacon grease you
don't want to use the grease use peanut
oil or vegetable oil well by now your
fire should be matured you should have
some nice good coals take your Dutch
oven spread out some coals stick it over
there and get that grease warmed up it
shouldn't be smoking but it should
sizzle very nicely when you drop some
hashbrowns in it you want enough grease
so that the bottom is barely covered in
a pool of grease when you lay the
hashbrowns down in the oil you should
see a little bit of oil bubbling up to
the top once that is done you're gonna
take some eggs and lots of them and
you're gonna beat them up
you're gonna add your salt you're gonna
add your pepper and you're gonna add
your meat and your vegetables you're
gonna make a nice omelet mixture and
then we're gonna pour it all on top of
those hashbrowns those hashbrowns are
gonna take the brunt of the heat from
the coals and hashbrowns need a lot more
heat to cook in an omelet does and you
pour in the egg you'll notice that some
of the oil comes up along the side
that's good you don't want it pooling on
the top but you want oil bubbling up
along the sides that'll keep it from
sticking to the side so that your pie
comes out nice and easy when you're
cooking over coals each breakfast pie is
a little different but I'm gonna give
this one about 20-25 minutes and
hopefully they'll give us the brown
crust on the outside and have it cooked
all the way through about 13 to 15
minutes in take the lid off and check
your breakfast pie see how it's doing
by now the sides should have cooked and
separated from the wall of the Dutch
oven also you should notice that there's
lots of oil bubbling on the side if you
find out you did add too much oil and
starts pulling up
just take a spoon and start ladling it
off but if you jiggle it you'll notice
that the inside is a little slushy and
that's when you'll tell when it's done
is that when you kind of jiggle the
cast-iron in the center doesn't move it
all moves is one piece if the sides are
getting too Brown to quickly adjust the
coals now mine here is getting a little
bit burnt on the sides I've got kind of
an intense heat coming in from the side
so I need to spin it and I need to
remove some coals from the bottom and
cook it more from the top and less from
the bottom if you've properly seasoned
your Dutch oven and you've used enough
oil the pie should just come right out
of the Dutch oven without needing any
encouragement I burned it a little bit
on this side that's okay it actually
looks pretty darn good there we go
that's a breakfast pie let's cut into
this thing
[Music]
all crust is crunchy I like my
hashbrowns crunchy there we go that's a
breakfast pie with hash brown crust and
bacon crumble on top that looks
delicious
[Music]
all right you ready to try some
breakfast pie hey that is an entire
breakfast in one mouthful and a good
breakfast of that Oh the onions and the
peppers really really make it more than
just eating eggs and bacon and yeah it's
crunchy on the bottom it's crunchy on
the top right amount of right amount of
egg and meat let me try the back the
back crust here you've got a little
little toast here than I would have
preferred but let's see that it's
filling it should be there's like three
pounds of meat and 18 eggs in here and
like four potatoes well guys I hope you
enjoyed this video as much as we enjoyed
eating this if you want to see more
cooking videos we got tons of them whole
playlist in fact also check out our best
stuff video with 23 of my favorite
campfire cooking recipes you like what
you see don't forget to click Subscribe
but we put out new videos every Saturday
morning thanks for watching if you like
this video don't forget to check out the
outdoor Boise
we have hundreds of videos just like
this don't forget to click subscribe so
you can see other great videos every
Saturday morning hit that belt like
you'll get notifications thanks for
watching
[Music]